we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p the last
couple days I've taken a lot of hits as
a result of my coverage of the
Democratic primary a lot of people don't
like that I don't see a mathematical
path for Bernie to the nomination there
are people who don't like that when it
comes down to it in November I'm going
to vote for Biden over Trump and I've
outlined the reasons why a lot of people
angry with me we took several hundred
unsubscribes on our YouTube channel
yesterday as a result and listen it's
that's okay you know I mean what I can
only do the show the way I'm gonna do it
I'm not gonna do any of this stuff where
you know I give people false hope that
doesn't make sense or I pretend like the
only reason Bernie lost is because of
the DNC establishment like I'm not gonna
lie to you okay if you want that or not
necessarily if you don't not that you
want people to lie to you but if you
want people to tell you that you can
find shows that I'm sure are doing it
and here's a voicemail I got sort of
related to this big picture issue David
what is wrong with the progressive
movement right now after the drumming
Bernie took it on Tuesday all I'm
hearing from progressive sources is a
bunch of excuses and fear-mongering
they're now trying to impress upon their
audiences that Joe Biden can't possibly
Beach from what the hell is going on do
they want from to win this is not
helpful and they keep talking about how
Bernie still has a chance look at the
analytics he is not favored in a single
state left right now keeps doing
horribly amongst black people he is
doing well with Hispanics but he's doing
horribly with Hispanics and Florida
Bernie can't win and we need to accept
this he's only getting about thirty five
percent of the vote his constituency is
not showing up yeah that's that's all
true and you know I I understand you
know having been through a bunch of
these elections now and thinking back to
the disappointment when George W Bush
was eventually get awarded the
presidency over Al Gore that's the first
presidential election I followed really
closely I I get the feeling I know what
people are experiencing
my argument is we don't do any better in
future elections if we just say guys you
know what happened
it was the establishment and it was the
media that made it so that Bernie lost
and he still has a chance if that's your
view the same thing will happen next
time okay we have to include in our
analysis the electorate is not as
progressive as Twitter and reddit make
us think the electorate may like
Medicare for all in the abstract but
when you say exactly how it will work
it's not as popular I got into Twitter
arguments yesterday about that guys this
is just the reality it's not my opinion
when you give more detail about Bernie's
medicare-for-all plan support goes down
doesn't mean it's a bad policy doesn't
mean it's the wrong policy but it's not
just the media okay it's not just the
DNC Joe Biden right now is leading
Bernie by 1.5 million votes the idea
that this is simply because the DNC took
it from Bernie if you if it makes you
feel better go with it but we will not
win elections when that is the
predominant analysis and I want to win I
want to win that's my concern
and I also when it comes down to it I
don't want Donald Trump choosing Ruth
Bader Ginsberg Ruth Bader Ginsburg's
replacement I don't want that I'd rather
it be Biden you know III get that we're
gonna have some some audience rollover
as a result of this because there are
people who just don't want to hear that
here at some people we will lose for
good some people will leave for awhile
and then eventually come back I can't
engage my commentary or calibrate my
commentary on that basis I just have to
tell what I see is the truth if you see
the data differently that's a great
debate to engage in Kyle kolinsky and I
did that on Twitter yesterday we went
back and forth about some of these
Medicare numbers but you know calling me
a centrist as a pejorative all of that
stuff aside from being untrue and me
being more progressive than I've ever
been in my entire life based on all of
the countless tests you folks have sent
me in that I've taken um we're not gonna
win by saying oh if I believe Bernie has
lost I am a centrist shill we're just
not gonna win and maybe that's what some
people want maybe some people want to
perpetually be in sort of the victim on
the outside position and that there's
something to be said for that that can
feel good
- a lot of people there's a lot of
psychology that's going on here that
sort of exceeds my ability to mention
mention here but I hope that that we can
all sort of come together and agree as
to what it is that that is going on this
election we have a great bonus show for
you today Donald Trump wants big shocker
a bailout for the hotel industry the NBA
has cancelled or suspended the remainder
of their season as multiple players now
have the virus and Harvey Weinstein
Weinstein I get convinced it's Eric
Weinstein Harvey Weinstein has been
sentenced to 24 years in prison and that
is a big case which we will be talking
about on the bonus show today get access
to the bonus show don't miss it grab a
membership at join pakman.com or make a
pledge on patreon at patreon.com slash
david pakman show